das ist wirklich ein super spektakulärer
plan der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa bei der mission
kommt interceptor sollen drei raumsonden
einen kometen abfangen der sich
erstmalig auf dem weg in das innere
sonnensystem macht eine echte premiere
also denn so könnte zum ersten mal ein
komet untersucht werden der von der
sonne noch völlig unberührt ist im
glücksfall könnte vielleicht sogar die
analyse eines interstellaren objekts
gelingen wort klicks um science-fiction
jetzt täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
bringen die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
jetzt gibt es grünes licht für diese
neue wirklich spektakuläre mission der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
hier ist der name programm kommt
interceptor übersetzt also so viel wie
kometen upfinger besteht aus drei
raumsonden die auf abfangen kurs gehen
im visier ein objekt das sich vorher
noch nie der sonne angenähert hatte
zusammen mit dem weltraumteleskop ariel
sollen die raumsonden 2028 ins all
starten dann werden sie quasi im
weltraum geparkt aus sicht der sonne
könnten sie dann hinter der erde auf ein
passendes zielobjekt lauern dieser
sogenannte logos punkt l2 liegt 1,5
millionen kilometer hinter der erde da
gleichen sich alle kräfte die der
geschwindigkeit rund um die sonne
mit gravitation von erde und sonne aus
und die sonden brauchen keine energie um
ihre position zu halten
die drei komponenten der mission
bestehen aus den sonden a b1 und b2 die
sich dann laut plan kurz vor der ankunft
von einander trennen und das zielobjekt
dann während des vorbei fluges aus
verschiedenen blickwinkeln analysieren
das hat den vorteil dass der komet von
mehreren punkten aus gleichzeitig
beobachtet werden kann echte 3d
informationen werden also das ergebnis
und könnten zum verständnis dazu
beitragen welchen einfluss diese
sonneneinstrahlung auf kometen hat und
wie er mit den ständig wechselnden
sonnen winden interagiert alle drei
sonden sollen optimal ausgestattet
werden sodass sie nicht nur in der lage
sind den kometenkern zu messen sondern
auch seine staub gas und plasma umgebung
analysieren können 2028 wird die mission
ins all starten und die reise kann
monate oder sogar
dauern schließlich ist nicht wirklich
absehbar wann ein optimaler kometen
kandidaten entdeckt wird heißt also im
klartext kommet interceptor könnte eine
ganze zeit lang im all herumlungern im
worst case vielleicht sogar so lange bis
ihm die energie ausgeht bevor überhaupt
in richtung eines kometen gestartet wird
als notfallplan hat die esa deshalb
bereits ersatz ziele ausgewählt kometen
die wir bereits kennen laut plan der
weltraumagentur soll die mission fünf
jahre nach dem start im jahr 2028
abgeschlossen seien 150 millionen euro
sind dafür eingeplant doch der ganze
aufwand wird sich lohnen da sind sich
die fachleute einig schließlich erlaubt
diese mission erstmalig ein kosmisches
fossil genauer zu analysieren
denn das zielobjekt soll ja ein wirklich
ursprünglicher comet sein der
unberührtes material aufweist das vom
beginn des sonnensystems stammt und
außerdem noch nicht durch die
einstrahlung der sonne verändert wurde
noch einmal anders gesagt das zielobjekt
wird also eines sein das zum aller
ersten mal aus den aller äußersten
regionen des sonnensystems in die
inneren regionen kommt solch ein
besucher kann beispielsweise ins innere
sonnensystem gelangen weil in den
äußeren regionen des sonnensystems zwei
himmelskörper kollidieren und sich somit
ihre bahn ändert um dann in die nähe der
erde zu kommen brauchen solche besucher
tausende jahre nach einer runde um die
sonne dauert es wieder tausende von
jahren um zurück in ihre alte ferne
heimat so lang so lange wollen
forschungsteams natürlich nicht warten
und da kommen wir schon zu dem riesigen
problem dass astronomie teams weltweit
hatten die zeitspanne zwischen der
entdeckung eines solchen sogenannten
lang periodischen kometen und dessen
vorbeiflug an der erde ist viel zu kurz
jedenfalls reicht diese zeit nicht aus
um eine raum mission ins all zu planen
zu bauen und zu starten
genau deswegen ist das konzept der neuen
esa mission so erfolgversprechend
die fertigen raumsonden erwarten einfach
im all bis irgendwann ein optimaler
kandidat vorbei kommt dazu der
esa-direktor für wissenschaft dasinger
unberührte kometen sind völlig unbekannt
und bieten ein hoch interessantes ziel
für die erforschung aus nächster nähe um
die vielfalt und entwicklung dieser
objekte besser zu verstehen
durch die beiden vergangenen esa mission
giotto und rosetta die ja auch kommen im
alle erforscht hatten konnten bereits
wichtige erkenntnisse gesammelt werden
85 war die auto ins all gestartet um den
halleschen comet zu erforschen 2000
war rosetta auf der oberfläche des
kometen tschurjumow gerasimenko gelandet
eine total aufregende sache denn dadurch
konnte nicht nur ein komet aus nächster
nähe beobachtet werden wir sind sogar
noch darauf gelandet doch der
unterschied zur neuen esa mission liegt
auf der hand sowohl zur ihm oft
gerasimenko als auch der halleysche
komet waren bereits durch den einfluss
der sonne verändert worden doch der esa
reicht das eben noch lange nicht
zumindest der besuch eines unberührten
kometen sollte also auf jeden fall drin
sein im besten fall könnte sogar ein
intercell jahres objekte als zielobjekt
dieser missionen dienen so die
insgeheime hoffnung der
weltraumorganisation dazu günther
hasinger jetzt ist es an der zeit einen
unberührten kometen zu besuchen oder
sich auf das nächste uno ähnliche
interstellare objekt vorzubereiten
humor war im herbst 2017 mit einem
teleskop auf hawaii aufgespürt worden
wir hatten hier bei klicks und wünschen
ja ausführlich darüber berichtet bei dem
400 bis 800 meter lang brocken oder
sonnenlicht säge wir wissen es ja nicht
genau handelt es sich um das erste eben
sonnensystem entdeckte objekt das aus
dem interstellaren raum stammt nach
meinung von astronomie teams weltweit
wohl kein einzelfall und so besteht
tatsächlich die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
die neue esa mission solch ein
exotisches objekt abfangen könnte klar
ist aber auch dass diese
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht besonders groß
ist die jagd auf humor beginnt ein
aktuelles megavideo von neugier zone
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
den ama kanal neugier zone bis dann
bleibt dran